Chris Hayes it's so wonderful to have
you here thank you a con Yin in a nation
is really an important contribution to
America and the world I think right now
so I'm wondering how what kind of
brought you to this topic maybe to talk
about your trajectory from quite a
twilight of the elites which looks at
meritocracy to this very kind of
compelling and compassionate work on
American criminal justice and law
enforcement you know I think so there's
a few strains I think like in some ways
both books are books about the same
thing which are like what I would call
democratic pathologies like if you think
about the body politic as a body that
has different processes and functions
and they can go wrong in different ways
that both books are sort of diagnosis
about infections infirmaries in the body
politic right so like ways in which
though I'm a real believer like my one
core sort of secular faith is like
democracy small D democracy and that
like democracy is the most radical
profound idea in the history of human
civilization and it's so radical and so
profound that we have a hard time
maintaining it thinking through its
implications constantly being rounded
and returned to our conceptions of like
freedom and so Twilight elites is about
ways our democracy has gone bad through
sort of outsourcing a lot of it to a
sort of set of elites and this book is
about ways our democracy has gone bad by
essentially putting a subsection of our
population under conditions that are not
really free and the fundamental way we
want to be free so I think they sort of
relate in that way in terms of the
specifics of this look I mean I'm all a
kid you grew up in the Bronx it was just
like my core identity it's I'm a white
kid who grew up in the Bronx in the
1980s which was which I would never
trade for a million years in terms of
what it meant to me in terms of the way
that I think about race politics but it
was really fraught and the city was
really dangerous and I think that like
I've thought about crime and policing
and criminal justice all through my life
in all sorts of different ways and what
I encountered as I was doing reporting
of Ferguson and Baltimore was like
beginning to see
the sort of conception became able to
see the system that we've built from
these different kind of angles like what
I experienced growing up in New York the
appeal of Giuliani and the certain kind
of rhetoric what it is wrought for
communities of color and it felt like it
was useful that maybe kind of synthesize
that it seems like Ferguson is really
kind of an anchor and in many ways in
the book so I'm like I'm wondering how
you're experienced reporting they're
kind of illuminated what you're talking
about growing up in the Bronx in the 80s
yeah the thing about Ferguson that blew
my mind was I think for like if you grow
I think if you grow up in a city and you
grow up the Bronx you have this
conception of cities as distinct things
right so that in cities there are these
racial frictions and cities you have bad
neighborhoods and good neighborhoods all
kinds of like loaded ways in which
police police communities differently
all kinds of loaded ways in which the
borders of different neighborhoods sit
atop each other interlock and overlap
and create this sort of sandpaper
friction all of that to me was tied very
deeply to either the Bronx to New York
or cities because then I moved to
Chicago when I live in Chicago and I
lived in DC and all these things pertain
in that place the thing that blew my
mind about Ferguson was like it's just a
municipality of 20,000 people
it's totally it could it's anywhere USA
it's between the northern edge or st.
Louis and like the tonier suburbs you
just drive through it it looks like a me
where it's just strip malls and parking
lots and houses and and the idea that
what I experienced there was like the
level of exploitation and the level of
racial oppression and friction the level
of the invasiveness of policing the
intensity of the humiliation all of that
just in this place that was heretofore
anonymous something about that blew my
mind it wasn't that I was like oh I
didn't realize that people felt this way
about police like I had experienced that
in New York I'd report about it it was
something about that experience in this
place that national media had no idea
existed that made me also think a how
many other Ferguson's are there like how
many other places you know we have this
amazing DOJ report about the Ferguson
patterns and practices and we only have
it because in though because Michael
Brown was shot and killed in the wake of
there were protests and the wake those
protests the DOJ came in and they
undertook a comprehensive investigation
of the department and they looked at
emails and all this stuff but they just
shined a flashlight at one place almost
at random in certain ways if they took
the flashlight and they just went to
like some other place in you know
Milwaukee County would they find the
same thing I think they probably would
one of the things like in the book you
say Ferguson was kind of hidden in plain
sight
can you give a specific example of
something that really kind of moved you
while you were reporting there that like
Ingrid you or that would you be like I
need to write this book to explain
what's going on and make this not hidden
anymore you know I had this experience
where I went down there and I would just
be talking to people all day and what I
found was that I could just literally do
this on air I could on air in a live TV
program I could just take my microphone
and be like to a african-american
resident of Ferguson and say tell me
about your experience the cops and just
story after story after story and you
could just tell from the what you can
tell when people are like telling the
truth about traumatic things and when
they're like this was just people just
telling these stories that were shocking
I mean the state senator who tells a
story about like in high school a fire
truck was that I forget what if it was
that Street Fair you know sometimes fire
trucks are around and a fire then
invited her to sit in the fire truck
which is like that sort of iconic part
of being a kid and a police officer
pulling the gun on there she a state
senator and it was just and then someone
else was like you know who's like his
class valedictorian and wants to like is
like a youth member of the n-double
a-c-p talking about his 60
something-year-old mother like pulled
over and thrown against at the back of a
car and then other people who you know
who's experienced the kernel justice
system is more meshed in you know they
have had they have longer criminal
records they have been engaged in the
drug trade talking about harassment and
cops using the n-word etc etc and I
could just it was just boom boom boom
boom boom like just microphone talk to
people people story after story after
story after story after story and one of
the things that is so important about
that department justice document in
certain ways is that it
you know it is a third party you know
confirmation it's a third party
confirmation of the the truth of what
all those people were saying nothing
that's needed but but but in a sort of
official sense it's like these are
official agents of the government
investigating these claims and saying
this isn't some sort of mass delusion
they aren't crazy I mean I joke about
this you know at one point I joke about
this in book events sometimes I've done
it in you know I feel like I have a I
have a unique position writing about
these issues because you know I don't
experience the law in the way that
people call or do I certainly don't
explain experience the law in the way
people color in neighborhoods of
concentrated poverty and violence do I'm
a reporter and in some ways reporting is
always this weird
you're always reporting outside of your
experience but this is a particularly
loaded one but part of the thing I feel
like part of the project of the book is
just to be like this is not made-up I
mean that's a ridiculous thing to say
and like why should it be the case that
people need to be vouched for in that
way but I do think that you know I just
saw some really interesting pew data
about this where like we are seeing
changes in public opinion among white
Americans about the reality and truth of
this stuff it actually is working
whether it's the the coverage of it it's
the videos staying protest it's the
activism public opinion is moving on
this stuff and I do think if you are
complete if you live your life
completely shielded from this experience
it seems insane it really does like if
you don't have a first-person experience
of it you're kind of just like really
did they really do that like a cop
pulled a gun on you in a fire truck why
would they do that well that's one of
them exactly I mean I and that that's
why I think the book is so important and
critical right now because I do think
that you're reaching a whole you have
the potential to reach a whole new set
of audiences with the book so let's what
you described to the residents in an in
Ferguson that you interacted with every
single one of them having some kind of
story to tell about their there- expand
to the criminal justice system that
speaks to the frame of your book
Ferguson is essentially a colony and I
thought the
that setting it up as a kannada nation
kind of drawing from black radicals anti
colonial activists and even Richard
Nixon I was shocked that he said black
America mix and himself said black
Americans don't want to be a calling an
in a nation so can you kind of lay out
what that what that in an analytical
framework is sure I think it's it's
fastening that Rick Nixon says that
because I think it speaks to the
intensity of the zeitgeist of the time
in which like that black nationalist of
view of internal colonization was so
prevalent that it would find its way in
this sort of osmotic way into the mouth
of Richard Nixon you know this is an
idea in some ways it goes there's their
seeds of it and Du Bois it's carried
through I mean partly it's sort of the
Garvey frame Kirk actually in its own
kind of way that that you know but
particularly the nineteen sixties right
the moment of this sort of like third
world solidarity which is like the term
people use then which we don't really
use now he's a little South but but you
have this you know you have these
movements of Independence and
nationalism against sort of colonial
oppression in which people of color have
been colonized by white folks and they
are they are working to get
self-determination and there's this
amazing cross-pollination that's
happening between black civil rights
activists here and that kind of work
happening all over Kirk particularly the
African continent and that's all kind of
in the air at the time I think when that
comes out of Nixon's mouth and that's a
tradition I mean you know Malcolm X
would explicitly call like you know
Oakland and once PG said was colonized
territory and and the Black Panthers
would speak in this way and black power
actually go black nationalism actually
comes out as a book by Kwame Turay I
think in 68 or 67 right so all these
ideas have been developed and there's
all this really interesting scholarly
debate about whether that framework
works right that the the colonial the
colonial framework is one of
exploitation as opposed to oppression
right where the populist is actually
exploited in the way that say slaves
were exploited in the way that say the
mine workers of potosi Bolivia are
exploited which is to say they're not a
surplus population they're actually
needed to produce the surplus value
right and there's a question about
whether African Americans and se9
mid-century
1960s America are that are they just
sort of a surplus that populations
suppressed or are they actually being
like used and exploited in this kind of
classical colonial fashion and that's
like a deep academic debate part of the
project here at is to take that notion a
little bit out of the kind of Marxist
contacts and put it closer to home with
like our own colonial experience right
so to me colony here means the
subjective experience of state authority
as external the the the the experience
of the state and particularly the most
powerful violent parts of the state
which is the policing function right the
experience of that is external authority
and the the connection between that
experience of this the the function of
the state is external authority to the
experience of our own colonial
forefathers who experience the crown as
external Authority and literally fought
a revolution about that in many ways can
you can you actually talk about one of
the things I thought was so interesting
about the book is the ways in which you
tie in our colonial past to make this
argument can you link some of the
earlier struggles during the
Revolutionary period to what we're
experiencing today because that really
comes through beautifully in the book I
think the rope you know we think of
other revolution as being about taxation
and representation no taxation without
representation and it's sure like
taxation is this sort of the point of
conflict but taxes at the time are not
collected through automatic payroll
deductions and like filing with the IRS
April 15th right they are almost
entirely collected as customs duties and
the enforcement of the customs duties is
done by customs agents who are in the
most literal sense law enforcement they
are cops they they go around they have I
don't know if they have badges or not
but they are cops and they apprehend
people they bring criminal trials
against them in courts they take goods
that are smuggled so what you have at
the time of the crown is you have this
incredible black market that's actually
kind of gray market it's really
interesting it's one of these things
where it's like a huge amount of goods
are moving in and out of the colonies
being smuggled outside
the reach of the customs laws and
there's this kind of look the other way
because everyone in the involved sort of
understands it's the lifeblood of the
colonies and the smuggling is so central
that even extremely high status figures
like John Hancock who's a smuggler are
engaged in this right like the smuggling
is the lifeblood you the one product
that the colonies produce better than
anyone else's rum and that rum is coming
from a sugar cane that's coming from
colonies that are with outside the
British reach are all being smuggled in
so you've got these distilleries that
are making all this money so the the
crown decides to crack down and they
sort of inaugurate what I first I call
the first stop-and-frisk era which is
they they basically decide like we can't
look the other way because we need that
revenue we want to crack down and get
those taxes and when they crack down
what it means is like searches of
everyone all the time you have these you
know these sort of official documents
that allow these very widespread
searches and people freaked out like
there's an official freak out in the
courts there's Benjamin Franklin writing
about it and John Adams writing about it
there's mob freakout where like someone
gets apprehended and a mob will grab the
customs agent and beat him bloody in the
middle of the street or tar and feather
him and march on through the the streets
of Newport or Boston
they'll smuggle back they will steal
back Madeira wine which is some
Portugal's that smuggled in that is
confiscated by customs agents
there's jury nullification where customs
agents can't get any prosecution they
cannot get case convictions because no
jury will convict customs officials are
bringing like case after case after case
and they're winning like ten percent of
them right because the norm of the
community is like this is okay with us
and so the the key insight here to me is
and I didn't I have to give a shout out
to Peter andreas his great book smuggler
nation which has a great work on this
the key to me is just understanding how
much law enforcement and smuggling was
the point of this here it was like
though it was the point of friction that
was the thing and there's this John
Adams quote where he says when he goes
to this famous trial where a lawyer is
essentially defending the smugglers
against unwarranted search and seizure
he says then and there was a spirit of
revolution born like everyone who
watched this went away saying like
this's our great cause and in the
Declaration of Independence Thomas
Jefferson writes in his bill of
complaints about the crown that the
crown hath sent us warm that the crown
has sent hither swarms of officers to
harass our people and eat out their
substance which is just him sang at the
police I mean almost literally eons of
officers swarms of officers like go talk
to people in Ferguson go talk to people
in New York City in neighborhoods that
are policed under the worst excesses of
stop-and-frisk swarms of officers to
harass our people and eat out their
substance like well well as you call it
he said in the book I mean the parallels
of purchasing are so clear like the
police there operate I think you said
eyes armed tax collectors Yeah right can
you talk about the ways fines and fees
and extraction are kind of working in
Ferguson and hat like just to emphasize
those parallels from Ferguson I think
Ferguson's the neatest parallel because
going back to this question about
exploitation for suppression right it is
they are extract it's fundamentally the
police department there is a extractive
and in the the documents that are
produced by the various authorities in
Ferguson for the DOJ review you have
emails between the city manager and the
sheriff and the police in which they
talk about policing is function as a
revenue function and this came out in
the DOJ report this is like we're
talking about like can't we need to get
your new enforcement zone up to prime
the revenue pipeline meaning like you
need to go out and start writing more
traffic tickets so we can get that
traffic ticket revenue to make our
budget and this is a this is a zero-sum
game I mean they are instead of doing
things like raising property taxes right
they are jacking up enforcement of
traffic violations so that they can
extract revenue to pay for municipal
costs that will save them the political
pain and the the wallet pain of raising
taxes to rather means so you have you
know the the the the report is very
clear and the statements of the
authorities themselves in their emails
they talk about it openly is that
fundamentally the department's goal is
to produce revenue for the municipality
and particularly through traffic
enforcement and not just through traffic
enforcement they have this in
system where it's almost like a payday
lender so you get $100 ticket you get a
court date summons right but the courts
only opened like six hours a week and it
always has more people showing up to
court that can actually be processed so
you stand on line and then you don't get
in and then you get a citation for being
apps in a court that then cost you money
and then you have to come back again and
then the fee balloons and then you don't
have enough money to pay for it so you
try to pay half of it and they charge
you a fee for a late payment so people
can start off with a simple parking
ticket there's a story of a woman in the
DOJ report it starts off with a simple
parking ticket who ends up owing like
six hundred dollars and being arrested
and put in jail three times because she
has outstanding warrants on her right
like that's the thing that's so
dangerous and this happens across
America right small infractions a small
infraction plus a missed court date
equals a warrant and then the next
person that person the next time that
person is interaction with the cops and
their plate is wrong that their ideas
run oh there's a warrant next thing you
know you're in jail you can end up in
jail for a thing that started as the
most minor kind of initial offense right
I mean these when I hear this I mean I'm
laughing cuz it's just so absurd yeah
and also angering so you detail these
practices and what's going on in New
York City with or what went on with with
broken windows and zero-tolerance and
the ways in which the criminal justice
system has been used to essentially
manage citizens so I'm wondering if you
can talk about how citizens in the
colony as you describe our police
entirely differently than citizens and
the rest of the nation you know so
there's this sort of famous Atlantic
article written by James Wilson and
George Kelling in 1982 is public called
publish called Brooklyn windows and I
would say it's got to be one of the most
influential magazine articles ever
published it's a me I mean this it was
just a magazine article this is not a
scholarly piece that was peer-reviewed
or just was in the Atlantic by the I
mean the two people that did her
academics but it was a public and it
starts off actually it actually starts
from an interesting and in some ways
actually really good place the initial
experiment that they that they are
writing about is a Newark experiment in
which they basically are trying to get
cops out of their cars and to walk the
beat which there's a lot of reason to
think that's good right and the
experiment is if cops focus on what they
call order maintenance not just the law
but order maintenance will they reduce
crime what's incredible about that
article is that actually the the the
experiment they cite finds no reduction
in crime but what they do find is a kind
of placebo effect which is that people
report feeling safer and they then take
this finding to make an argument to
completely sort of reorient policing
towards an older model of policing which
they weren't very explicit about like
they're like we want to go back to the
sort of the good old days before the war
in court before all this procedural ISM
before Miranda they even sort of joke
about there's all sorts of things cops
would do to maintain order back in the
days that you know rough up the young
ruffians that wouldn't pass legal muster
now they're basically saying like we
want to go back to this old order
maintenance model of policing which
truth be told was a model of policing
for a very long period of time in the in
the face of what's been this or Warren
court revolution and we want to focus on
order maintenance and what order
maintenance means is you you know to use
the title of the book right the that if
there's one broken window in a
neighborhood what it says what it
communicates to the community is no
one's police saying no one's watching
you can break other windows so there's
one broken window it lead to more so if
there's a group of teenagers drinking
out of an open bottle next thing you
know you get muggings robberies murders
right that there's this sort of like
slippery slope cascade in which the that
that if you think of you know the order
of a community as a kind of like woven
garment and if you just start pulling at
the loose threads through these small
infractions before you know the whole
thing is unwound that's the argument and
it's just enormous ly influential even
though the fundamental empirical case
has never quite been settled in any
different
way like there are all sorts of studies
about order maintenance and crime and
some find a small effect some find no
effect but what happened was this idea
of policing of focusing on order gets
adopted particularly in New York City
and it gets adopted right before a crime
starts falling in New York City
extremely dramatically and it produces I
know and I don't think unreasonably or
insanely it produces a causal story for
everyone to go tell so Rudy Giuliani
says I'm gonna get rid of the squeegee
men which were the scourge of New York
City in my youth which is that you'd
stop at a red light and almost always a
man and almost always a man of color who
was poor would come to your window and
start washing your window with a
squeegee and then you would have this
you would be kind of essentially kind of
cajoles or also paying now in this way
that felt like in tips vaguely
threatening but also just sort of put a
knot in your stomach people didn't like
it what you again like yeah it's fine
and not like that it was sort of a pain
that but that became that the sort of
symbolic villain of the Giuliani era he
was gonna wage war on squeegee men and
not only was he the symbolic villain but
that like the idea was that there was
this causal chain that linked the
squeegee man here to murderers here and
that by going after the squeegee man you
would stamp out murders and what
happened was Rudy Giuliani went after
squeezing men policing in the city
became much more aggressive order
maintenance became much more of a sort
of priority and also crime went down and
sewed Rudy Giuliani and William Bratton
who was his police chief at the time and
then went to LA and implemented there
and then came back to New York and
everyone could say look this is the the
the the basic causal theory work now
again
20 years later 30 years later we still
don't have a good handle on why crime
dropped as precipitously as it did and
there's no definitive empirical work
bearing out this basic thing was what
actually happened but police and city
administrators believe it deeply and so
what you have now is a sort of
fundamental reinvention of the justice
system in a city like New York in which
and ISA Cole our Houseman at Yale
University is written this incredible
incredible empirical work on this where
the misdemeanor court system
it's like entire massive court system to
patrol public urination public drinking
selling M&Ms on subways selling handbags
on the street all these municipal
violations that are part of the broken
windows sort of code of enforcement and
then you start channeling people in this
huge funnel into a criminal system whose
job is basically to kind of sort people
between the kind of people who will show
up for a court date and you could be
done with them the kind of people whose
lives are so disordered that they don't
and then next thing you know you have
felony convictions so the question is
like where do we go from here I mean you
pull out one of my favorite James
Baldwin quotes about what it's like to
live in the colony that you imagine
which is like the only way to police a
ghetto was to be oppressive he writes
and nobody knows my mate my name and
that police operate I think he as a
occupying soldier right and it bitterly
has outsole right what how can we
improve relationships between yeah
people on the colony and please since in
many cities like Ferguson the people who
are being policed live in the colony and
the police officers themselves live in
your conception of what the nation is I
mean I think I've I have through the
writing the book had become convinced
that we have to in some ways undo a
little bit
the keling Wilson revolution and there's
some part of me that is freaked out
about coming back conclusion because in
some ways I like not having brokenness
about the book like the experience of
the city really changed and and it
changed for people like me who were not
subject to stop and frisk right the cost
were paid by people I didn't see didn't
you know in neighborhoods that I wasn't
spending a lot of time in that you know
but the the sort of fundamental kind of
alteration the meson sin of the city was
pleasant and there's some fear of like
okay or didn't go back to the battle
days or to be graffiti on the train and
all the stuff but I do think that like
the fundamental idea of order
maintenance is the role of police is
particularly in communities of
concentrated poverty and violence is is
per is
has created toxicity I also think there
has to be a way people talk about
community policing
you know there's Camden is a sort of
interesting example where they've
implemented these sort of community
policing protocols that have both
reduced crime and also reduced
complaints against police officers I
think at at the most top level way we
have to view the job of this whole
system of producing safety and security
as opposed to order mm-hmm or even
lawfulness right I mean it I mean like
like actually the thing we want is
safety and security we also want to find
channels we need to have I mean another
priority and this is the flip side of
this whole conversation which is really
explored in Giglio V's great book get
aside about homicide and homicides
clearance rates right like the double
edged the other side of the coin of like
the devaluation of black lies when they
lose their lives the hands of the police
is like the devaluation of black lives
when they lose their lives murder like
it has been historically the case I mean
there's something back in 1966 milk nice
exist 63 Malcolm X gives this speech
where he's like he literally is just
like how is it the case that the most
violent neighborhoods also have the most
police and yet still have the most like
right what what was wrong with this
picture which is still the case today
and one of the things she focuses on is
that and she kind of makes the case that
she's got a great line about the sort of
modern police's system is like a bully
that will like intimidate people over
small infractions but is revealed to be
a coward in the face of murder
Rover police scene and under protecting
people over policing and under
protecting that's that is exactly the
problem in a nutshell and part of it to
you and you raised this in the book is
that you know policing in the colony is
so much about getting the bad guy right
instead of helping people so I think
part of it is like okay what if we
approached Public Safety and policing
itself as something that's like a
service that's about helping people and
not necessarily about locking as many
people right there's nothing the thought
and I always run in my head is like what
if there was one sort of mental health
counselor and one addiction counselor
for every one cop on the west side of
Chicago actually like just I I almost
mean this isn't like a literal sense
like I would love someone to fund this
experiment just like pick let's pick a
neighborhood that is a lot of crime and
let's just say you know a la you know I
think there's a back and forth about the
Harlem Children's Zone and what it said
I'm not but but that was a sort of in
another context a sort of idea right
like what if we put these resources
together for people like what if we just
said like let's pick a neighborhood in
Baltimore Chicago that is experiencing
exactly this over policing and under
protection right these dual problems and
we just said let's approach it with this
sort of full spectrum of resources where
we say like the police are one prong of
a three-legged stool along with like
addiction and mental health and conflict
mitigation and there has been stuff with
like you know the interrupters and cure
violence and people have done stuff
successful violence interventions along
those lines but they have not had the
resources of a police department one
ends up happening always right is like
more money goes to the police exactly
and and and and there's a kind of
amazing thing the police are able to do
and again I I don't wanna I don't want
to leave people with the idea that I
think this is bad faith there are a lot
there are so many police officers I've
talked to who are in good faith what
want to protect people and want to see
crime go down and people at high levels
of it administrators who are data-driven
and it really like sophisticated
thinkers about this stuff and like if
you look at Baltimore right now it's
extremely upsetting what's happened
there since Freddie Gray's death I mean
the homicide rate is a emergency and
there's a real grappling with like what
that means right but fundamentally
there's this amazing thing police
department has been able to do which is
that if crime is going down right then
police need more money because what
they're doing is working and if you cut
them off then crimes gonna come back up
if crime is going up then they need more
money because they don't have enough
money to keep crime down so you have
this incredible argument we're like a
police department is always weather
weather things are going well or poorly
there's always the sense that like you
need more police and you get more money
please let's see because we dis invested
so much from social welfare programs
okay past 50 years I want to get back to
something that you said earlier about it
was really interesting about the fear of
okay what happens if we do completely
get rid of broken windows style or order
maintenance I out policing because one
of the central concepts in the book that
you that you use to kind of explain how
we get these policies is white fear
which I thought was really interesting
so you write I'm gonna quote you this is
in the book
white fear expresses the forbidden
knowledge that all white people carry
with them we've got it better and if
white people have it better than isn't
it only logical that black people will
come and take what we have you then go
on to talk about the the belief kind of
like stemming from this that that that
what's good for the colony is somehow
bad for the nation we see this so much
playing out in our electoral arena and
kind of even the ways in which different
groups interact so I found this just
extremely kind of profound and it could
be a way to think about developments in
US history from like the so called
Indian Wars the fear of sleeping bullets
the Jeffersonian
probably because like it was true in
certain ways you know the the the the
fun the foundational experience of the
country right is essentially white
people coming to a land that's not their
own and conquering subverting settling
it while through incredible struggle and
violence at the huge cost of the lives
of other non-white people but also as a
subjective experience of hardship and
terror like you know it wasn't like what
we did it you know like the experience
of the colonies are just unceasingly
terrible and terrifying they're way less
terrible and terrifying than the
indigenous people who are rendered
extinct but they are subjectively that's
true at the frontier it's even true like
if you go and read the handbills that
were passed around the southern planter
patriarchy during slavery where the they
were constantly worried about slavery
Mill right it's led to me even as you
win you conquer you're on top of the
social order it's the kind of
precariousness of that on top nests
the sense that because you're on top
because you have because you've sort of
won this zero-sum game game that you
have to defend it all the time because
people are going to come for it and in a
literal sense like a lot of the stuff
that the in the early foundational years
of the colonies was zero something
there's this land
you're gonna farm it or I'm gonna farm
it so I think that that that experience
of kind of white fear that experience
that this sort of twinned feeling of the
ability of white people to feel
terrified while committing atrocities
like we look at the pictures of lynching
now right the people who go to lynch
mobs like they would tell you what they
were doing was defensive that they were
enforcing a social order because if they
didn't their women would be and you know
part of that is an excuse for savagery
well part of its like an actual
subjective experience and so I think
like it's just really important to that
core feeling that I have a version of
when I think about like what the city
would be like if it was police
differently and what that would mean for
my life there's two there's two ways of
thinking about the zero-sum mess right
and there's a really interesting debate
I feel like right now about this one is
that and I feel like a lot of black
intellectuals that I really respect
really do say white privilege is an
actual tangible material gain at the
expense of black people and that it is a
version of a pie that has been cut with
one slice significantly bigger than the
other right that's one way of viewing it
like it is kind of zero sense it is sort
of zero-sum it's a material gain at the
exploit at the expense of a material
loss for non-white people the other way
of viewing it is like a kind of social
pathology that stands in the way of
mutual human flourishing right that that
I am of the belief perhaps partly
faith-based that a less
and less widespread society would be
better for white people I really do
believe that like and partly I think
that because I believe in human beings
and I believe that like burning the
potential of a millions of people on the
bonfire of the criminal justice system
every year like absolutely makes us
worse off and poorer like we definitely
sacrifice collective wealth betterment
through that process I also think that
like white fear is a shackle of its own
kind I mean what can you talk about that
a little because one of the things that
I really appreciated in the book was the
ways in which you wove your own personal
experience is to kind of highlight the
your larger kind of socio-economic
analysis and so can you can you talk
about like your own white fear and how
that's shaped your the way you
understand these issues I mean I I think
I you know is really formative for me to
be in New York when I was twelve
thirteen commuting particularly and you
know when you're like a 12 or 13 year
old boy you're just a sitting duck like
you get like you save up money to buy
your fresh starter cap wish like you
know it's like or you're like or you
save up money to buy like you're fresh
sneakers or like you're like like dope
new winter coat and then you just like
Bop around basically being like mug me
just like the experience of of my
adolescence and so I just developed a
very like my experience of the city was
so enix trickily bound up with fear just
every step was like peripheral vision
like this very specific way of looking
that your eyes are up enough so that you
can see what's going on but not too high
that you ever make accidental eye
contact because that might initiate an
interaction you might plant the idea in
someone's head to mess with you who
didn't have it that experience was
really formative and it was really
visceral and I think and also sort of
socially cultivate
I mean that's part of what makes white
fear so potent it's that I call it in
the book like a call-and-response
you know between the the speaker and the
crowd you see this in Donald Trump
rallies and an almost literal sense that
you are individually experiencing that
fear and then it's being socially
amplified by the media you consumed by
the and so yeah you just come I think
you come to attach suspicion to
blackness and I think for me it was
mitigated by the fact that like that the
other thing that was happening in my
adolescence was that like blackness was
always also associated with kind of this
certain kind of like sophistication
coolness like aspirational in almost
some way like if you're in New York City
kid in high school it's like the
dominant culture to aspire to is black
culture so you have this very
complicated relationship with it and I
think that what's most interesting to me
is how potent it could be in the absence
of the experience right so as messed up
as as the as the racial politics of a
city like New York are and can be where
people are atop each other what's
amazing is how much that can be exported
to places in which that isn't the case
well I mean can you talk about that
because that's where it seems like this
concept is really key to helping us
understand the rise of mass
incarceration and why we have you grown
I mean in some places even more
segregated unequal right because I think
that we've you know Nicole Hannah Jones
we're gonna book about this based on the
incredible piece you did that won a
Peabody called the problem you live with
that a huge to parts of the story right
like all of this starts and you write
about this I mean this is in some ways
that these is your book like this this
era of what we do starts at the moment
of sort of the peak victories of the
civil rights movement in the sort of
chronologically bound sense that we
think of it and it starts at the moment
when you know du jour Jim Crow
discrimination and integrity
being dismantled huge flight is
happening up to northern cities and the
fight comes to northern cities where
essentially the fight is lost I mean you
get the Fair Housing Act which is in
some ways a kind of high-water mark but
then you have the busing fights and you
get what you get or the is you get
essentially a society that gives up on
the project of desegregation as a social
project through a million different
distinct municipal decisions through
dozens of Court decisions that just
whittle away at it including recent ones
like parent involved parents involved
which essentially like makes it almost
impossible to create a desegregation
scheme voluntarily for a school district
through the abandonment of fair housing
legislation often like the enforcement
of it right so what person what
facilitates all this is that like it's
like okay we have people living near
each other we've given up on the project
of desegregation so in its place we'll
just put put in the project of like
corralling and controlling like that to
me is and and a big thing and I've come
a way to come to believe in writing this
book is that like it's actually should
be a priority to revive and resuscitate
desegregation explicitly in those terms
as a social project well so part of that
I mean because we are so divided and so
separate it seems like that that fear of
the unknown and white fear played out in
the most recent election and it was even
and it was exploited and kind of the
rhetoric but also in who showed up to
the the polls and why and what like make
America great again means that seems to
me to be playing into the politics of
weight fear so I guess I'm wondering in
the now in the context of the Trump
administration I mean clearly you were
kind of writing you've been working on
this book imagine well before the
election and then like writing alongside
it so I'm wondering like especially with
things like the DOJ report and with
sessions like where you think that we
are now with with Trump and like how the
implications of your book might be
different or the same or maybe just
reinforced I think I mean to me the book
is the project of the book is figuring
out why we built this and the and what
we saw in the election
a great example of why we built it which
is the here's my my sort of unified
theory of Donald Trump in in in respect
to the book the great mystery in some
ways the election was how does a New
York City urban billionaire real estate
air connect viscerally to the white
working-class voters of materially
decimated places across America outside
Youngstown Ohio right Mahoning County a
lot how do why why him and the answer to
me is that the man's worldview is formed
in 1980s and 1990s New York which is an
experience of material decline the place
is going to hell and it's done at the
hand of some other and it turns out that
that story is endlessly exportable
across the country so he went to Erie
County Pennsylvania in McDowell County
Virginia and Mahoning County Ohio and
Kenosha Wisconsin and said you're
experiencing your material decline we're
gonna bring you back to greatness and
it's those people over there that are
causing the decline now in this case it
was I think the sort of prime villain in
the story was immigrants rather than
black people but they're married I mean
in some ways interchangeable look with
the DOJ today today is we're speaking
the DOJ is announcing their new website
that will show crimes committed by
unauthorized immigrants which is just
this I mean there's gonna be official
project of the government to publish to
to essentially create in the public's
mind an association of criminality with
with unauthorized immigration and that
is the the project that was that was
sort of carried out over a course of
several decades through long order
rhetoric and Willie Horton etc to
associate blackness with criminality so
it's not an accident that Rudy Giuliani
was like his biggest campaign surrogate
and it's not an accident that Jeff
Sessions who said that you know the who
talked about police departments being
hamstrung by
these consent decrees is ahead of DOJ
it's like the worst impulses of
precisely what I'm not enter now
embodied in the highest reaches of
government the world view of the the
federal government embodies this
zero-sum idea it embodies this broken
windows idea in fact the border wall to
me is the most it's this literal
manifestation of broken windows about
yeah how so I just think that like
broken windows at some point at some
level the appeal of broken windows is
about sort of the the fear there's a
neurotic fear about unraveling and sort
of penetration and like the jungle
reclaiming that's like civilized spot
and so what what is more literally a
manifestation of that than the idea that
you will physically literally build a
border to keep out the disorder and not
only that sell that to people who live
1,500 miles from the border like what do
they care
think about the people that let cheered
the Mexico is gonna build for the wall
he's in a rally in Michigan okay he's a
hundred miles from the northern border
he's however many hundreds of miles
thousands of miles from the southern
border and people are curing that like
they're gonna build a wall on the
southern border like what do you care
what's that do to your life but what it
does is it in that same kind of broken
windows way and that same sort of like
fear of disorder and disorder as a
particularly kind of like authorized
non-white catalyst it it says I will I
will wall you off in the disorder that's
coming I will I will protect you from
the from the disorder that is
threatening your material well-being and
like that's the whole recipe I mean it
Sam it's for me it seems like it stems
from this idea that we see emerging
alongside civil rights in Johnson and
Nixon you quote this idea that the first
the first civil right is actually safety
and so I was wondering and then that
thing that I in my own work have
struggled with and thinking about okay
what are the implications for domestic
policy and it seems it's broken windows
it's the wall what do you think the the
the kind of first and foremost civil
right is do you think do you agree that
its safety
it's a really heart I mean it's a weird
if you frame it that way it's hard to
get away from it right like at at some
level I mean that's the right that's the
the title the miracle book which is you
know about about the way that you know
liberals built prison America and it's
the it's literally a quote of Nixon in
that same sixty-eight speech at some
level there's a core kernel truth to it
in the sense of like the Weber Aryan
bayberry an idea of like a monopoly on
violence like it is the case that like
what the state does at its most
essential core existential level is to
arrogate to itself the ability to
arbitrate disputes and to monopolize
violence and so a place like Somalia in
the midst of no state right is incapable
of extending any rights right without
like a functioning state but it also
seems like a weirdly low bar like right
right like if you well does it reflect
our event like I thought given some of
what you say in the book that you would
have said equality because I mean given
right get ribbon our values it seems
like and for there have been points in
American history where that has been
kind of championed as during civil war
with Abraham Lincoln for instance so but
I mean yeah I mean I guess I I just I
guess I don't think I reject the idea of
what a first civil right is like I I
guess what I would say is it like the
the the most charitable version of that
argument on the other side is that like
equality would be impossible under
conditions of warlordism which is true
right so yes like you have to
essentially produce some you need to you
need the basics of the state to produce
the kind of flourishing but that doesn't
mean that like that's all you should
pursue or like that's the bar clear
which is what makes it all so weird
right like one of the ways I want people
think about in this book and I think I
sort of explicitly have said it in book
talks and sort of say in the book is
like you got to think about the system
as costs and benefits and you got to
think about who it's costing and one way
to run the experiment if you live in the
nation you just don't have
interactions with the system you don't
know how it operates it's like what
system do you want if someone you loved
was accused of crime well actually that
leads to one of my favorite passages of
the book which comes in the form of a
series of questions so I'm gonna read
what these are I thought this is quite
profound what kind of justice system
would exist in a setting in which each
member of society were actually valued
as a full human with tremendous
potential even if he or she committed a
crime or hurt someone or broke the
community's norms and were held
accountable
what would a criminal justice system for
the elite look like how would people
with power and privilege and resources
and influence choose to collectively
police themselves back to what you're
just saying if you gave them the ability
so these are kind of like big
philosophical maybe impossible to answer
questions but I don't know what do you
think some of it like what would that
actually look like in some ways part of
what that looks like is campus justice
we're gonna run down a book it's like
right so we actually have these
situations we have parallel justice
systems at Brown University where we
work University of Michigan or Kenyon
College right did they actually have
like campus cops and they have campus
judicial codes and the campus codes very
interestingly like span violations of
norms and violations of laws which is
sort of hard to get your head around
like they are almost distinct legal
regimes right so there's drug policy for
instance like well that's actually a
violation of Ohio law right of federal
law in certain cases but it's it's in
the same spectrum of plagiarism right
the the the the community says like
these are our laws and even sectional
being a series of sexual assault is in
there as well right so I love by the way
how you describe to college campuses as
I mean the way that people talk about
low-income black and Latino communities
they're like this orderly they're these
kids who sleep all day early and in fact
like Wallace I call it it's like I call
in the book like elite Rumspringa yeah
the idea is that like it we actually
package the whole thing as like some day
you're gonna be like a successful
investment banker a lawyer or doctor but
you're kind of wild in those years and
finding yourself we're gonna send you
off to a place where like you and these
other adolescents could just like do a
lot of drugs and like have a lot of
non-marital sex
and and like but you'll be in the kind
of like rubber room where like nothing
you you won't be able to really hurt
yourself too badly because you'll be in
this environment it's like you're gonna
go bowling with these like inflatable
things in these in the gutters right and
and that's where that's like and that
what that is literally is like you're
not gonna get arrested and get a record
day and it's not understood as
pathological no it's understood as our
part of it I actually think like I have
some theory that a huge part of crime
and disorder in pathology is actually
about the way that human beings are
supported through their adolescence and
early adulthood okay I think that when
you look at how elites deal with it they
just throw an unbelievable honor
resources at people during that period
of their life which is a very difficult
period for lots of reasons it's a period
of which like it's very easy to get
knocked off course it's very easy to
like where peer pressure has an
incredibly profound effect that will and
I think this is like in a kind of sort
of non lofty way like actually a
universal truth about human beings look
almost biologically or sort of socially
essential to adolescents and young
adults and I think that college a huge
part of that like the way that elite
communities deal with that period of
time with the resources they have and
the structures they build for them as
opposed to like impoverished communities
are able to is just hugely different but
it's actually a lot of the same stuff
it's like peer pressure rebellion
substances sex and romance that's you
know that that is and like what is gangs
but peer pressure wanting to belong what
do
gang beasts that end up at homicide tend
to be about they tend to be about sex
and romance and like so we're like
feelings of dishonor or out-group and
it's like all this stuff is like real
deep fundamental sorts of stuff that
gets dealt with in totally different
ways in totally safer ways yes I'll talk
about how campus justice to this is
totally different using lis forgiving is
basically the the top line take away the
headline is you got a really go out of
your way really go out of your way to
get a criminal record
Brown University a lot of things are
tolerated and not only that it would be
outrageous to the parents that are
spending all this money of these places
if getting caught with weed in your dorm
room gave you a record like because the
idea is as I asking that question like
you're a human being with huge potential
that some veering off course shouldn't
be a thing that gives you a criminal
record and puts a permanent stain on you
that identifies to future employers that
you're disordered in some way you're one
of the people who's ordered you're in
this place we're adjusted where justice
system is constructed to be like really
forgiving about transgression and also
and I want to be clear-eyed about this
too as I am in the book like sometimes
the detriment in the case of sexual
assault right like there is a
relationship between those two things
like the idea of like oh these are all
bright future stars it means that like
we're not gonna come down too hard on
the kid who had now has three different
sexual assault claims against them right
so like it's not like you never escape
they're like real tough questions of
what to do and how to design a system
that punishes and holds accountable
people that commit acts of violence or
transgressions of community norms like
that's always a target question about
where you put the level but it is
instructive to look where elites but the
level when they have total control
basically of designing the system but
also I mean like like you say I think
related to these assumptions and white
fear that like some groups are Cena as
harboring amazing potential where others
are seen as potential criminals or
potential delinquents and don't even
having like I mean I think that the you
know the I say in the book that like we
in the political rhetoric of crime we
don't talk about crime we talk about
criminals we don't talk about acts we
talk about essences in the context of
elites it's acts right it's like Dennis
Hastert who was apparently serially
sexually abusing boys well he's a high
school wrestling coach got letters from
his buddies in Congress saying like this
is a good person and that's because they
have separated in their minds they've
separated the essence of Dennis Hastert
from the acts he committed
that's something that people are really
able to do when they know the person or
love the person but when it's some other
we reduce them to this the act well part
of that okay so is is I think
recognizing everyone's humanity which
one more quote we only have a few more
minutes but I want to get this in
because it's really important it speaks
to that question of resources you asked
I think this is towards the end what
would it mean if the nation and the
colony were joined if the borders are
raised and the humanity the full
outrageous maddening humanity of every
single human citizen were recognized in
our society or even just to start in our
policy so I know this is like a hard
question we talked about some of this
but like how do we begin to get there I
concretely like how do we get rid of
that border between the two I do think
the first place to start is an in like
citizen to citizen and like civil
society and building civil society
together like I do think that genuine
multiracial Democratic egalitarian
movements are like the hardest things to
build but they can be built and when
they are built when you look at like the
fusion movement that's being built in in
North Carolina right now moral Mondays
people come to really view each other
through collective work together there's
always this idea of like we need to have
conversations and like I actually don't
think I think work I think like being
together and doing the work together the
work of citizenship the work of civil
society the work of activism the work of
politics working on campaigns together
like that's the thing that does it more
than conversation because that's how you
actually produce the thing in miniature
with all of its pitfalls and conflicts
and that doesn't mean people will all
get along or or people don't say really
dumb stuff and people get angry at that
dumb stuff they say but it does mean
that like it's the activity of being
jointly active together that that sort
of begins to embody the beginnings of
that to me how do you get given you know
like though the extent of white fear
that you lay out in the book how do you
get white people to overcome that and
say okay I don't want it I want to build
this multiracial egalitarian I think you
know that's why I do think that like
actually that's why I think fighting on
things that aren't explicitly about
racial justice can bring people into
contact with racial justice right like
that's kind of the potential of okay I'm
planning to save my Medicaid and you're
fighting save your Medicaid or I'm
fighting for $15 minimum wage and you're
fighting for $15 min or wage and I'm not
in a fight for racial justice I'm gonna
fight for a wage but you and I are in
this fight together like there there are
there has been shown time and time again
that like people being organized around
their concerns along like deeply
anti-racist and sort of racially
pluralistic lines can produce changes in
people and how they think about this
stuff even if the place they're starting
from isn't I'm signing up for this
racial justice fight well let's hope
that we can begin to build that movement